bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 22
novembre texto est un petit ours qui
rêve d'aller retrouver son grand père
installé en laponie le pays du père noël
un ours au pays du père noël est un
droit jeunesse de véronique bar d'autun
et michel breton ils ont tous deux
choisi de reverser leurs droits à une
association
bach corelli l'alouette un choeur
d'enfants et un trio de musiciens seront
en concert le 10 décembre à versailles
dans le cadre du festival au son des
orgues et elle remet ça pour la
troisième année la famille déclic se
retrouve sur les planches de la mairie
samedi pour le rendez vous du début de
saison
trapp un pro féminine des adultes aux
instruments aux voix des enfants de
formation propose un concert de musique
à l'interprétation le jeune concerts et
la badinerie un trio de musiciens
le concert est prévu le dimanche 10
décembre à versailles
[Musique]
esther tessier 16 ans interprète le
magnificat de jean-françois l'alouette
une oeuvre de 10 726 le 10 décembre
prochain est le chantera à versailles
dans le cadre du festival au son des
orgues avec elle des instrumentistes de
la badinerie des pièces baroque du xviie
siècle de la musique également
instrumentale du du xviiie siècle avec
jean sébastien bach et un corps et
l'hymne il y aura des pièces
instrumentales seul un magnificat de
l'alouette forcément nous avons une
organiste qui participent puisque
sans elle pas de concert de toute façon
donc l'organiste du jeune concert david
shivers violon et puis donc moi la flûte
baroque foot avec
[Musique]
esther fait partie des sept chanteurs
qui composent le jeune concert ils ont
tous entre 11 et 18 ans l'information a
été créé en 2016 par hélène bruce on
leur propose de travailler en très haut
niveau mais en dehors du temps scolaire
l'idée c'était de créer une sorte de
maîtrise en dehors de l'école plutôt
d'être une maîtrise ou les enfants
doivent avoir un concours un cursus à
être tous scolarisés dans le même
endroit où on puisse les faire les
lycées l'idée c'est totalement libre des
sonates des mots t'es français et
allemands du temps de l'avent la
badinerie et le jeune concerne l'eau
ainsi un avant-goût de noël
c'est l'amour
versailles à un palais public de sa
construction à la révolution française
le château de versailles retrace avec
son exposition les visiteurs de
versailles ce passage obligé pour les
grandes familles européennes une
exposition thématique qui montre le
voyage vers la cité royale
lannoy de vestimentaire à adopter ou
encore les rencontres avec le roi des
précisions avec bertrand rondeau fou
versailles est une étape essentielle au
xviiie siècle et dès la fin du règne de
louis xiv en europe dans cette europe du
grand tour donc de ses voyages
initiatiques et éducatif que font les
personnes fortunées donc versailles est
à l'égal de rome devient l'égal de rome
une des étapes essentielles du grand
tour épatant pour les oeuvres d'art même
si on les voit que pour la vie de cour
la sociabilité qui est tout à fait
unique en europe
la famille déclic se rassemblent à
nouveau ce samedi c'est la troisième
édition de trappes impro family pour en
parler nous reilhac et louise de déclic
bonjour alors samedi vous vous remettez
ça exactement on met on remettra d'impro
family sur la scène de la mairie alors
une soirée traditionnelle de match
d'impro presse que cette fois encore
pour cette troisième édition vous faites
jouer la famille et bien voilà c'est ça
c'est des comédiens qui ont un parcours
au sein de notre compagnie en tant que
qui ont été formés ou alors qu'ils ont
un moment donné un passage
on les a rencontrés que on s'est attaché
à eux on les a adoptés si je puis dire
et puis et puis voilà donc on essaye
tous les ans de recréer un nouveau
plateau de deux comédiens qui reviennent
ou alors qu'on découvre à trappes dans
ce cadre là la famille tournée de chacun
alors comment choisir des gens choisis
avec la famille proche parce que bon on
va essayer de ne pas heurter ceux qui au
quotidien font la compagnie et puis
après on va voir un petit peu ceux avec
qui on aimerait croiser un peu le frais
le faire sans annoncer qu'il ya de la
compétition dans tout cela mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est c'est cette
pouvoir en tout cas voilà avoir cet
événement là qui est devenu maintenant
un événement récurrent est qui et qui
permet justement à des gens qui ont un
moment donné donné de leur temps à
déclic théâtre à trappes à
l'improvisation comme on prend part aux
commandes proposons voilà un moment de
demande en pâtit totale avec les autres
comédiens et puis surtout avec le public
trappistes c'est une compétition bon
enfant
alors sans menace toujours il n'y a pas
de trophée derrière mondial des juniors
pour les collèges alors oui il y a il ya
un trophée non il n'y a pas de trophée
sur ce match là parce qu'on le veut
comme un match de gala mais on commence
à réfléchir
avant tuellement créer des d une plaque
peut-être sur un mur à déclic théâtre
juste pour annoncer en tout cas calé les
vainqueurs ou en tout cas ceux qui ont
joué entre cannes parce que le côté
vainqueur il est peut-être un peu trop
inscrits mais mais en tout cas annoncés
ceux qui sont passés et puis et au delà
de la victoire on va remettre au goût du
jour ses gardes et dans certaines knicks
a beaucoup disparue dans le monde de
l'improvisation mais l'improvisation fil
d'or qui sera décerné voilà pour les
joueurs qui auront proposé aux aux yeux
d'un membre du public la meilleure
improvisation et du coup c'est quelque
chose qui existait dans le match
d'improvisation qui a été un petit peu
abandonné qu'on va essayer de remettre
au goût du jour et dans la patinoire ce
soir là on peut pas citer tout le monde
mais il y aura notamment amel amziane
laetitia bis julie galibert anneaux
joaillier mounir de l'âne antoine
rameaux oui je veux dire mounir dan à
votre place parce que du coup on aime
bien et alors où il y aurait il y aura
il y aura il y aura tout ça il y aura
aussi gentiane 29 elle qui est la coach
de l'équipe belge qu'on a rencontré
pendant le mondial il y aura caroline
marge parce qu'il avait cité mais pareil
qui est une jeune un profane jeunes
improvisatrice non une jeune fille une
jeune femme est une très ancienne
improvisatrice de déclic elle a commencé
avec nous à 8 ans et elle est encore là
elle aussi qu'elle appelait avec le
huawei
en coaching ces lignes d'eau pèse
ferreira qui pareille et de quasiment
toutes les aventures de déclic théâtre
depuis l'an 2000 où elle nous a
rencontrés
justement tout seul en forêt présager un
bon niveau jeu ça reste de
l'improvisation donc un bon niveau oui
parce qu'on a pas on a la prétention de
faire des spectacles de qualité à déclic
et je pense qu'on propose des bons
matchs d'improvisation
après on est surtout on a après ça reste
de la rencontre
et surtout ce qui est intéressant parler
de bon niveau c'est compliqué en impro
en tout cas on crée des rencontres hyper
intéressante on crée des vrais moments
de 2
des fois de drôlerie des fois j'ai foi
d'émotion des fois c'est touchant des
fois on essaye de proposer un panel
large de choses en tout cas dire que
l'improvisation
on y va parce que c'est drôle oui mais
c'est si on regarde entre les lignes à
plein d'autres choses général avec vous
le rend bien les plaines et bien les
deux dernières années on a refait le
compte là sur deux trappes impro family
on en est à plus de 1000 personnes déjà
et puis voilà cette date s'annonce
encore bien remplie la voile pour donner
il n'y a plus beaucoup de place s'il ya
encore des sites sait s'il ya encore
mais c'est déjà bien avancé en tout cas
et vous même si vous saurez sur scène le
sang mais dans un rôle
le emcee le maître de cérémonie du thé
vous êtes larbitre ce qui est plutôt le
méchant on va dire gentil alors
d'habitude arbitre oui mais je ne suis
pas que arbitre l'année dernière sur
trappe après midi j'étais joueur
j'ai déjà fait des voilà des choses en
tant que coach mais je suis capable de
chez un peu caméléon moi je suis capable
de tout faire sans vous là sans
prétention mais en tout cas je serai à
maître de cérémonie je suis très content
de le faire maître de cérémonie c'est
particulier parce que c'est ça reste
c'est le monsieur loyal et et vu que mon
rôle aujourd'hui à déclic théâtre et de
de coordonner un petit peu toute
l'activité improvisation de de permettre
à des comédiens et puis j'ai une vision
aussi j'ai connu les anciens pardon j'ai
connu les anciens je connais les
nouveaux et du coup ça me permets moi
d'avoir une posture un petit peu voilà
de guide dans tout ça sans aucune pré
nation c'est notamment le travail
profane ville lance la saison tout à
fait tout à fait bon à l'aller déjà bien
aller d un petit peu avancé mais mais
mais ça va être notre premier grand
rendez vous merci merci merci merci tv
78 alors tu rapport aux familles les
samedis 25 novembre à 20h30 à la mairie
de trappes
en panne d'inspiration pour votre
programme cinéma bertrand pin et vous
donne rendez vous écoutez cette semaine
aux yeux d'elsa le coup de coeur
c'est tout notre programmation alors
tort ragnarok confident royal
zombillénium demain et tous les autres
jours et puis surtout la semaine
prochaine et pousse bois mon pote donc
la comédie des créateurs de baby sitting
et puis un film que nous aurons sur
trois séances à partir du 1er décembre
beautiful day un film de lynne ramsay
qui a valu à joaquin phoenix le prix
d'interprétation à cannes et le prix du
scénario
du coup voilà s'il semble que c'est un
film important un peu particulier dont
on dit c'est le drive le taxi driver de
6,2 cette année c'est probablement un
peu exagéré
parce que c'est pas exactement le même
film mais en tout cas c'est un film qui
sera une vraie claque un vrai couple
dans le ventre et que je vous invite à
venir découvrir du coup dès le 1er
décembre au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
saint-cyr-l'ecole béaba pour le festival
de la bande annonce de bois d'arcy la
troisième édition se déroulait ce
week-end un carton plein avec un cinéma
la grange complet le point avec marylène
iapichino et les images de camille
lambert l'ail et faire de la bande
annonce un marc à part entière c'est
l'objectif que s'est fixé la ville de
bois d'arcy il ya trois ans avec le
festival et à bas la ville compte bien
montrer que ce petit film résumant leurs
grands frères sont un vrai travail
il ya des bandes-annonces magnifique
dépendamment ce qui vous donne envie
d'aller voir un film
des bandes annonces qui sont des films
en tant que tel et il fallait rendre
hommage à cette a7 à cet art qui a été
oubliée jusqu'à maintenant
le festival est désormais bien installé
aucun fauteuil vide dans la salle qui a
même je refusais une centaine de paires
est ce que vous pouvez lever le doigt
ceux qui étaient là au moins qu'une fois
déjà venu au moins la soirée était
rythmée par des thématiques avec un
hommage à bourvil les grands classiques
ou encore les couples à la scène comme à
la ville
nous allons ce soir vous promener
pendant deux heures dans toute
l'histoire du cinéma et on va avoir 34
films et oui parce que d'une certaine
façon c'est vrai c'est dans une version
résumée
mais on voit 34 films etc ce qui
logiquement doit donner aussi envie d'en
voir d'autres et de revoir ce dont on a
assisté à la projection de la bande à
l'isthme déroule cette année on passe de
l'autre côté de l'écran avec
l'intervention de l'uqam à son un jeune
réalisateur français de bande annonce
venu présenter son métier
la clé c'est de donner envie aux
spectateurs et c'est de se donner envie
à soi même aussi c'est pour moi c'est
une passion et c6 et c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment stimulant et il faut
que ce soit donc
finalement c'est cette envie et que son
côté stimulant se traversent l'écran et
arrivent jusqu au public pour qu'il
vienne ans avant le festival s'est
poursuivi le lendemain avec son édition
junior au vu du succès de cette
troisième édition les organisateurs
réfléchissent déjà aux thèmes de l'année
prochaine un autre festival avait lieu
ce week end le festival à saint quentin
qui s'est terminé ce dimanche avec la
remise des prix pour sa troisième
édition
un festival du film documentaire tourné
cette année vers la musique
retour sur cette soirée de clôture le
festival saint quentin s'est terminée
comme il l'a débuté en musique
une troisième édition tournée vers le
4ème art le prix des cinémas a
récompensé à l'unanimité youssef le
gambré ce documentaire s'attache un
musicien et luthier youssef serra
locales comme on le voit dans le film il
habite crap
c'est quelqu'un qui est l'immigration
qui s'est marré qu'une française
donc on trouvait que son parcours était
vachement intéressant vachement positif
parce qu'en fait lui il veut y arriver
on a trouvé que c'était un comment
dirais-je à un beau film en fait sur le
sur le partage sur la tolérance voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on lui a décerné le
prix des cinémas de 50 à enlever je fais
des instruments je suis la connaissance
avec une visite ranger bah ça change
beaucoup pour moi
le prix tv 78 a été remis à une
réalisation suisse avec vénus en
caroline
harnes et martina rider plonge dans la
tradition musicale des yéniches un
peuple semi-nomade le choix est multiple
il ya le thème qui était très original
et qui n'étaient pas connus de nous
avant de visionner le documentaire il ya
le lieu il ya la qualité des images à la
qualité du montage c'est absolument
évident il ya la découverte
même si on ne voit pas beaucoup mais
quand même un stephan eicher qui nous
surprend même dans son engagement
[Musique]
le prix troisième revient lui à anaïs
prosaïque réalisatrice deviendra dit
l'écoutent virtuose et le public aussi a
été invité à s'exprimer les votes ont
pris fin ce mercredi à 22 novembre et
c'est le documentaire de guy peyrat qui
l'emportent
opéra junior l'enfant créateurs il suit
les répétitions de pollicino de hans
werner henze par les enfants de l'opéra
junior une structure unique en europe
regardez
[Musique]
je sais pas
oui
donc l'eau
l'eau
wissant
il sait
et puis de pouvoir jouer avec ça boit
comme ça je trouve ça formidable de
pouvoir
c'est un instrument qu'on a toujours
avec nous et je trouve que c'est un des
plus beaux
c'est comme un petit diamant une petite
pierre précieuse qu'on peut sortir à
tout moment pour regarder son éclat et
pour l'avoir prier ou lomoro ça se passe
sur la gauche ce soutien et vous
épanouir au début de l'été que tout
membre
c'était n'importe quoi puis très vite on
a compris où ça se trouve et c'est ici
le mot
[Musique]
les indices us
et
ni
[Musique]
ce qui me
dans un petit peu plus d'un mois c'est
le réveillon de noël une fête qui
inspirait véronique barbotin bonsoir
bonsoir alors votre ouvrage s'intitule
un ours au pays du père noël où on suit
ex-haut un petit ours
oui en fait c'est un petit tour ça qu'il
arrive une aventure un petit peu
particulière parce qu' eelv a souhaité
retrouver son grand père en laponie et
donc avant de préparer son voyage il va
passer par la bergerie par exemple de
rambouillet donc on reste en même temps
dans le local avant de partir pour le
grand voyage en laponie et à nouveau la
peur de noël vous inspire oui en fait je
me suis retrouvé dans cette période que
se trouve magique pour les enfants mais
aussi pour les adultes et qui m'a permis
que mon fidèle illustrateur michel
breton puisse à nouveau comme pour
petite histoire au pied du sapin qu'on
avait eu le plaisir de présenter chez
vous également
eh bien il puisse illustrer donc là je
vois que des files quelques-uns des
débats 5 et qui accompagnent les
ouvrages
justement pourquoi avoir fait encore
appel à michel breton c'est quoi ces
dessins
s'adapte bien à votre à vos histoires
votre univers oui alors en fait c'est
vraiment une rencontre où j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'à chaque fois que
j'écris quelque chose michel comprends
tout à fait ce que j'ai voulu dire
et honnêtement le personnage de techsoup
a été inspirée de l'association dont je
vous parlerai mais on est parti vraiment
sur quelque chose où les les postures de
textes où c'était vraiment moi j'ai pas
le talent de michel pour pour dessiner
et à chaque fois lui on a l'impression
que c'est le prolongement crayon de
demandes reçues lors de votre stylo
alors vous disais il passe par la
bergerie de rambouillet il ya toujours
cette petite rambo liten parce que c'est
votre viennent voilà c'est ma ville j'y
suis très attaché et je trouve que c'est
c'est l'occasion bien à travers mes
histoires de faire justement découvrir
aussi toutes les possibilités qui peut y
avoir à à rambouillet et donc bas la
bergerie m'a paru un lieu justement très
approprié pour noël et c'est un ouvrage
à découvrir à partir de 6 ans à se lier
avec les parents nettoie la bonne voilà
en fait à partir de 6 ans peut 6 7 ans
les enfants peuvent le lire tout seul
quand ils sont plus jeunes à partir de 4
5 ans c'est les parents leur liste c'est
un livre qui est quand même très
abordable puisque là il ya des
illustrations qui sont en couleur et
j'ai essayé que le personnage justement
puisse s'adapter en fait à des enfants
aussi plus jeunes donc du coup on a
on a des parents qui qui aime bien
passer du temps avec les enfants et qui
du coup vont transformer les différents
chapitres en autant de petites histoires
justement c'était aussi un moyen de
faire patienter jusqu'à noël en sec là
dans le mois ça va être plus compliqué
les enfants vont assister aux
éliminations la course aux cadeaux la
lettre au père noël un petit ouvrage
comme ça vous le pensez aussi quand vous
l'écrivez alors moi en fait je pense
surtout que c'est une occasion
formidable pour les enfants de se dire
que à travers le à travers noël il ya
aussi à toutes ses étapes qui sont
autant de autant de chapitres et que les
histoires de noël
c'est un moyen physiquement de faire
patienter alors vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous l'avez mentionné brièvement
l'association alors elle s'appelle louis
car le 6 mo qui elle apporte une aide
psychologique et matérielle aux enfants
gravement malades
alors la particularité c'est que vous
avez décidé avec michel breton de
reverser tous vos droits d'auteurs et
d'illustrateurs à cette association
pourquoi parce que en fait je pense que
le rêve d enfant ça doit être pour tous
les enfants y compris les enfants
malades
cette association
elle m'a paru tout à fait intéressante à
plusieurs égards d'une part parce
qu'elle existe depuis 35 ans donc c'est
quand même quelque chose qui s'inscrit
dans la durée
son responsable le nord- est quelqu'un
de passionné qui essaie de tout faire
pour que les enfants sortent de
l'hôpital mais en toute sécurité avec
des médecins ou avec des infirmières
avec mais il leur permet de sortir de
l'hôpital et donc là il va emmener de 35
enfants en laponie
donc c'est pas un hasard si ses parents
laponie voilà il va emmener 35 enfants
gravement malades en laponie qu'ils vont
rencontrer le père noël là bas et je
trouvais que du coup écrire une petite
histoire comme ça c'était en même temps
un petit clin d'oeil pour que la maladie
de vienne pas quelque chose de triste
mais au contraire un signe d'espoir
alors un livre pour enfants pour aider
d'autres enfants
c'était aussi pour faire comprendre vous
espérez peut-être que les parents
précise alors leurs enfants l'intérêt du
libre pour pour moi ça veut dire qu'en
fait non seulement aygalades ya la
lecture mais il ya aussi au delà de la
lecture le fait qu'on participe à
travers ce genre d'action a aidé au
départ de ces enfants en laponie à idées
l'association avoir pas mal de projets
et du coup je pense que par rapport à ça
l'idée c'est c'est de se dire que quand
on peut faire plaisir en plus c'est
encore mieux injustement vu que vous
êtes là pour aider vous faites ces
ouvrages pour aider les enfants malades
pourquoi ne pas mettre peut-être des
enfants malades dans vos ouvrages que tu
es plus tard sa vue donnant alors
j'avais écrit un livre un bateau de rêve
où le petit garçon est malade il ya
quelques années et là en fait je
m'adressais à cette époque-là pas aux
enfants malades et c'est vrai que depuis
que je m'adresse à eux du coup j'ai
essayé de prendre des des personnages
qui sont en fait qu'ils sont plus des
héros type d ours ou des animaux voilà
ce moment auquel je pense qu'ils peuvent
aussi avoir cette impression de liberté
parce qu'ils n'ont pas ce problème
d'être dans une chambre d'hôpital
peut-être l'imagination du doudou voilà
qui part ça vous
merci votants alors un ours au pays du
père noël
on le trouve aux éditions au pg com
merci et on passe tout de suite à notre
agenda
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un siècle le cinéma
transforme notre manière de voir le
monde le documentaire de stan newman
remonte là où le cinéma se fabrique
permet de découvrir aussi la face cachée
des images il est à découvrir ce samedi
aussi 17 à elancourt l'auditorium de
trappes résonnera lui des quintettes de
franck d inspiration amoureuse des élans
mystiques les solistes de lavilledieu
interne interpréteront aussi le
quintette de louis vierne une oeuvre
dédiée par le compositeur à son fils
mort pour la france le 11 novembre 1917
le concert a lieu ce samedi et à la
batterie de guyancourt ces seuils
critiques il se produit avec le groupe
original de son père aux touches
africaines sun kitty apporte sa propre
touche
extraits
[Musique]
lamentable
un rendez vous magique maintenant à
maurepas à cette fois c'est alain
choquette mètres de la grande illusion
et du close up
il sera sur la scène de l'espace albert
camus ce week-end au regard des salles
et vous bien car ce soir j'ai
l'intention de vous divertir de vous
mystifié mais surtout de vous traiter
comme des rois
vous avez reçu une enveloppe vous allez
délicatement
on va faire de la magie en semble prenez
maintenant la main droite comme sur
verre et vous les replacer c'est génial
regardez votre carte ainsi que celles
des voisins magie du théâtre pour
terminer avec un cheptel michel zeiter
propose un groupe de préadolescents une
ex première expérience de la scène le
chorégraphe a une ambition faire surgir
des réactions non formatés par les
normes du monde adulte
rendez vous au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines le statut de culture
est maintenant terminée je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivi le magazine est à
retrouver sur notre site internet où
notre application mobile et je vous dis
à mercredi prochain
[Musique]